Your turn
>> Thanks.
[NOISE]
You know, I've been thinking, this is a
really great analogy for how the human body works.
>> It's just a board game.
>> Well sure, but I mean, think about it, from the outside looking in, it's
a lot like the human body, it can
seem really complicated, like a Rube Goldberg machine.
>> What's that?
>> Well, you know? Something where there's a seemingly
simple task, right? There's just a trap coming down.
[SOUND]
But there's a ton of energy dependent steps that have
to be accomplished for us to get to this simple outcome.
>> I won.
>> You did win. Now, although it looks complicated. If
we remove just one piece from the machine here, we
can totally alter the end outcome, or the end result.
So, let's do it again and remove this little diver man
[NOISE].
>> Okay. So
I see, the whole game is like the human body. But there's obviously a lot more
genes in the human body than there are human pieces
in the game. Sounds like something a geneticist would study.
>> That's exactly right. But a geneticist doesn't study all the genes at once.
They still use the one gene at a time approach, meaning that they remove
one piece, and they see what happens. Now if
you remove one piece, and you actually can see
a visible, overall effect, then you know you've got
something important to the whole process. And this is actually
what geneticists call a monogenic trait A monogenic trait
is whenever one gene has a variation that effects
the overall outcome or phenotype. This lesson is dedicated
to inherited tratis that are influenced by single genes, or
monogeneic traits. We're going to cover traits
like, red, green colorblindness, dwarfism, osteogeneis
imperfecta, and sickle cell anemia. For each of these traits we're going to
uncover some of the genetic variations that cause these traits. And then also
examine the dominance of these various
alleles that contribute to an individual phenotype.
>> Here's the concept map for lesson eight. As always, I
want you to print it out and try to fill in the
blanks on your own as we go through the
lesson. Then in the end you'll have a chance
to see how you did. There'll be a complete
version of the map waiting for you at the end.